like a grown man and you were in
flip-flops i know i don't know where's
flip-flops of the [ __ ]
i do i do i know but it's called
destructive entitlement yeah my friend
so the tsa i go through a different
security line she can't even go through
the [ __ ] line with because i'm not
combative like that i just i'm like it's
pretty easy to get through
yeah what do you when i'm in line right
no matter how long the line is
my focus and my eye line is at the
[ __ ] guy
so even if it's like a 45 minute like
i'm just
the whole time walking looking at the
guy i can't wait to get in jessamy he'll
do this
he knows that certain things aren't
allowed on carry on but he's looking for
a fight
so he'll have something on there he's
too lazy to take the things out that he
knows he's gonna get caught for yeah
i'll put like bottles of water on the
bottom of the thing
yeah just just so they have to take it
all out
and then when they don't put it back
perfectly because yeah perfect
is that the way you [ __ ] opened it
yeah
and they oh no but this is a bottle of
water i go exactly the way you
you found it he's a karen he's an
airport karen
right and then you know i love when this
happens when they when you go to the
you give them the the ticket and your i
like id right and they get you through
to go to put your stuff through
the machines right so every once in a
while this is what i love when this
happens
a tsi just out of nowhere will walk up
to you and go
so where are you going
i love when that happened didn't i go
[Music]
do you really yeah because it's illegal
what they're doing
so you have what what is your beef with
airport they're just trying to
personalize you and in
and ari together that's that's where i
learned it
ari i never learned it why would you
want to take
like airport etiquette lessons from ari
but that's where i learned it i was at
the airport once and he goes yo dude
you're being too nice yeah
what do you mean i feel frustrated right
now he's like let your frustration
no he's jewish yeah koreans and jews
well they're i go they're like the
police they have no authority over you
they're not the police
they're not law enforcement they're just
you know they're just empty that's why
he's he's a poke the bear yeah and so he
taught me some of the rules and some of
the laws
when it comes to it but here's my strife
with them all right and here's my thing
is they owe me 42 000 lighters
because they used to [ __ ] after nine
nine was it
not eleven thousand forty two after 9 11
right they took every [ __ ] lighter
from me
why you think i'm gonna light it on fire
you know how hard
even if i wanted to [ __ ] light the
plane on fire with a lighter
hollow would that does that would never
work
would it i what is the what's the one
light everything looks flammable
on the plane you're right it's all
fabric i'm just saying but i'm not going
to there's like a
fuselage i don't know what the fuselage
sounds like a
like a room in in
in the rock's house it sounds like a
like a place
like a like a man cave on his property
yeah yeah like
you're right but i'm not gonna do that i
told you i wasn't gonna do that anymore
at the airport now have i done it
no not since he's gone in therapy and
he's been caught on his behalf
i don't do it i you know what i do know
i wait in line and i'm just
and then when they asked me i go yes sir
hey where are you going but he is
i'm going to um philadelphia to do a
show sir i'm sorry all right have a good
day
no no i'm just saying this is what i
would do okay yeah but i've been in
therapy for a year and i'm not doing
that anymore but
but um never mind go ahead is this
couples therapy or is it individual we
do some couples both that's great yeah
yeah i'm a huge proponent of that yeah i
love it